have you ever wanted to travel back in
time would you go meet your younger self
would you go and ride a dinosaur
or would you meticulously create a
timeline of the earth's 4.6 billion year
long history based on major geological
events even though geologists can't go
back in time they've been able to do
just that
their timeline is called the geologic
time scale and it breaks up all of
earth's history into units called eons
and eras and you might be wondering how
can we map out what happened on earth
billions of years ago
the answer is rocks geologists look for
clues in sedimentary rock layers which
we call strata
the fossil record which are the remains
of organisms that have been preserved in
rock layers can give us glimpses of
creatures that breathe long ago
also the difference in mineral
composition in different rock layers can
tell geologists when a volcano erupted
or an asteroid hit
but how do geologists know when one rock
layer is older than another well when
sedimentary rocks form they are
deposited in layers one on top of the
other so unless the layers are disturbed
or turned over the layers at the bottom
are always older than the layers at the
top geologists call this rule the law of
superposition
so if a geologist finds a fossil of an
ammonite in a layer of rock above a
fossil of a dunkleosteus the scientist
would know that the dunklosteus is older
than the ammonite this process is called
relative dating because it helps
scientists determine the relative ages
of rock layers and fossils
but what does relative ages mean
let's say that i told you my friend ava
is younger than her sister but older
than her cat then i wouldn't be telling
you ava's exact age but her relative age
in relation to her sister and her cat
let's take a look at another example of
relative ages this time with rocks
imagine that one day you found a big
rock with many layers like this
because the rock is a sedimentary rock
and you remember the law of
superposition you know that the layers
at the bottom are older
and you know that the layers up here are
younger but what about this section of
rock right here that slices through all
the other layers geologists would call
this section an igneous intrusion since
it was formed from molten rock that is
cooled
this particular igneous intrusion isn't
clearly on top of or below any of the
sedimentary rock layers so we can't use
the law of superposition here luckily
geologists have figured out another rule
called the law of cross-cutting
relationships
this rule says that when two geological
features cross or intersect the feature
that cuts through the other is younger
and this makes sense because you can't
break something before it even exists
so since our igneous intrusion cuts to
the layers of the sedimentary rock we
know that it must be even younger than
the rock players and what about this
fault or break over here
well since it slices through all the
layers as well as the igneous rock the
law of cross-cutting relationships tells
us that the faults must be the very
youngest geological feature here
other pieces of evidence like fossils
can be used for relative dating for
example suppose a geologist found a rock
containing fossils of extinct organisms
and another rock that contained fossils
of modern organisms the geologist could
then deduce that the rock with the
extinct organisms is older
certain kinds of fossils called index
fossils are especially helpful when
determining the relative age of a rock
index fossils are fossils that are only
found on a specific section of the
geologic time scale i always remember
what an index fossil is like this just
like i use my index finger to point to
give directions
index fossils can point to when on the
geologic time scale of rock was formed
so if a geologist finds the same index
fossil in rock layers in two different
rocks they know that those rock layers
must have been formed around the same
time period
but fossils aren't the only thing that
can help geologists figure out a rock's
relative age
for example if a geologist found two
rock layers that contained evidence of
the same geologic event like a layer of
ash from a major volcanic eruption the
geologist could deduce that those rock
layers were made at the same time
relative dating is how geologists
figured out that stegosauruses were
extinct long before t-rex's even existed
it also helped them figure out the first
single cellular life formed about 3.8
billion years ago and the first
multi-cellular life formed about 600
million years ago and they figured out
that modern humans didn't even exist
until about 200 000 years ago which is
right at the very end of the geologic
time scale
in other words it took a really really
long time for life to evolve into what
it looks like today we humans are very
young in the grand scheme of the earth's
history
now if you'll excuse me i'm gonna go
saddle and ride this brontosaurus let's
go gingersnap hey